[Música]
hola
antes de empezar tengo una advertencia
porque lo que hoy te voy a platicar es
adictivo porque cuando tú descubres que
puedes hacer especial lo que tienes
frente a ti a través de tu talento ya no
hay forma de parar porque tú existes tal
y como eres una sola vez en la historia
de la humanidad imagínate qué
impresionante esto significa que la
forma que tú tienes de percibir y de
interpretar el mundo es irrepetible lo
que tú dejes de hacer nunca nadie jamás
en la historia lo va a poder volver a
hacer como tú lo hubieras hecho por eso
yo estoy aquí para sacudir a todas estas
almas inquietas a que se atrevan a
explorar algo que llamó tu chac es tu
sello creativo en donde experimentas tu
mayor gozo y que además es tu mejor
regalo al mundo
además te ha acompañado toda tu vida te
acuerdas de lo que quería ser de grande
cuando eras niño
aquí me dicen astronauta superhéroe
policía doctor muchísimas profesiones
porque todo se podía esta es la etapa de
mayor libertad creativa de toda tu vida
y entonces pues te atrevías a hacer lo
que fuera y es muy revelador para tu
carisma porque entonces vas a descubrir
que lo que te moría
atrás de esa profesión realmente es una
emoción que probablemente es la que
todavía te mueve y te emociona yo por
ejemplo yo quería ser cantante pero no
cualquiera yo quería hacer de timbiriche
pero pues eso no fluyó entonces estudie
contabilidad
cosa rarísima para alguien que hoy se
dedica a la creatividad y de ahí me
brinqué hacer turistera evento loga y
ahora autor y conferencista y yo creo
que me faltan algunas reinvención es más
pero el común denominador de esa niña
que todo el tiempo jugaba con micrófonos
a esta persona que tienes frente a ti es
la emoción que ubicó durante toda mi
vida que es inspirar cuando la ubica
entonces la puedes empezar a vivir de
manera más intencional porque ahí es
donde te sientes más feliz como yo me
siento súper feliz de estar aquí el día
de hoy y esta palabra tarde además de
significar amuleto de buena suerte y
talento irrepetible además es mi apodo
desde niña porque mis amigos me decían
mari carmen mari carmen maritza charts y
entonces además de darme un apodo me
clarificaron mi misión de vida porque a
mí me encanta pararme frente a ti y
hacerte pensar en cuál es ese carisma
irrepetible con el que tú marcas
todo lo que eres y todo lo que haces
porque desafortunadamente el 85% de las
personas no se sienten conectadas con
este propósito no tienen claro cuáles
son y entonces se sienten mal y en
nuestra sociedad está súper condenado
sentirte mal te sientes mal de sentirte
mal no pero si tú aprendes a ver este
momento desconectado como parte del
ritmo de tu vida entonces lo vas a poder
aprovechar como una oportunidad para
hacerte un cuestionamiento auténtico
profundo de hacia dónde te está llamando
en este momento tu curiosidad tu
entusiasmo y tu charla porque la
naturaleza no está floreciendo todo el
tiempo y la música para que sea más
hermosa tiene silencios la poesía para
que sea más bella también tiene espacios
y tú no eres la excepción todo ser
humano para estar realmente conectado
tiene que aprender a vivir la belleza de
esos momentos
desconectados
porque toda persona y eso te lo prometo
y cada empresa tiene un chat es el adn
que las distingue de unas a otras porque
puede haber muchas empresas haciendo lo
mismo pero cada una lo va a hacer con su
propio carisma con su propio chan por
eso yo no creo en la competencia porque
aquí podríamos estar todos hablando de
lo mismo pero cada uno lo va a hacer con
su propia voz entonces la invitación es
a explorar eso que te hace irrepetible
como por ejemplo en los hoteles
doubletree tienen una práctica creativa
que me encanta que cuando llegas a hacer
el check-in a este hotel te dan una
galleta de chocolate chip calientita a
la hora que sea 8 de la mañana a 10 de
la noche
no importa esa galleta tiene el
propósito de ser una bienvenida cálida
para ti y te prometo que a lo largo del
tiempo ya no te acuerdas ni de la cama
ni de las instalaciones del hotel pero
no se te olvida el detalle de la galleta
calientita y ahora te quiero preguntar
tú crees que
es la única empresa que tiene galletas
de chocolate chip no inventaron ellos
las galletas de chocolate chip por
supuesto que no puede haber millones de
galletas pero sólo una como la que creo
construir y otro ejemplo que me encanta
es de una persona que tomo uno de mis
cursos y que no encontraba su cama
estaba traumada y decía es que yo quiero
ellos wedding planner quiero distinguir
me entre todas las personas que hacen
algo similar a mí pero a través de mi
carisma ya mí me gusta proyectar que soy
una persona feliz pero como que no nos
cuadraba el happy wedding planner o
happy wedding porque esa es una promesa
riesgosa entonces explorando su carisma
más a fondo
descubrimos que ella es una persona muy
energética muy valiente con mucha chispa
pero además con un corazón enorme
entonces definió que ella iba a
proyectar su carisma y hacerlo su marca
con la frase chispa y corazón para que
entonces ese sea el sello que la
acompaña a todo lo que hace
se ha convertido en una marca
reconocible y además es un pleno reflejo
de lo que ella es así que puede haber
muchas wedding planners en el mundo pero
solo una paula abreu con chispa y
corazón porque el factor común de todas
las creaciones de tu vida eres tú
entonces por eso me interesa tanto que
explores y descubras este hilo conductor
que te acompaña toda tu vida en todo lo
que puedas llegar a desarrollar te voy a
dar 5 tips para que puedas explorar tu
carisma y cuando lo encuentres por favor
compártelo porque me encantan estos
casos para yo tambien inspirar a alguien
más a través de ti el primer tip es
ubicar esa emoción de lo que te movía en
esa profesión con la que jugaba de niño
que te que sentías que te emocionaba y
como las relacionas con lo que hoy te
emociona todavía
el segundo tipo es explorar tu talento
algo para lo que eres tan bueno que para
ti es natural hasta se te olvida que
eres talentoso en eso porque para ti es
lo de siempre a veces se necesita que
alguien te lo recuerde como al de paso a
mi amiga claudia torre que un amigo le
pidió ayuda para hacer una mudanza en
tres días y claudia se la hizo en cinco
horas con cajas rotuladas lista de lo
que había en cada caja y el amigo se
quedó así como es en serio cosa esto no
es normal por favor explora esto que
acabas de hacer aquí porque aquí hay un
talento impresionante ella cómo crees es
lo que hago siempre y gracias a este
comentario ella empezó en un camino que
hoy es su misión de vida y es la pionera
de la organización profesional de
espacios
por ejemplo yo no he parado de hablar
desde que nací
mi mamá sabía que me quedaba dormida
porque de repente había oído nada y de
repente silencio y decía ya se durmió la
niña pero nunca me imaginé que eso que
es vital dentón natural se pudiera
convertir no solo en mi profesión sino
en mi misión de vida porque hablar es lo
que más me gusta inspirar es la emoción
que me mueve y por eso estoy tan feliz
de estar aquí contigo estoy en mi
elemento y ese es el tercer tipo como
puedes ubicar un elemento tangible que
te permita ser reconocible para ti y
para los demás cuál es tu galleta de
chocolate chip cuál es tu chispa y
corazón
el cuarto tipo tiene que ver con la
curiosidad y el entusiasmo para donde te
está llamando eso que te llama la
atención porque no es casualidad esas
son señales del camino en donde está tu
mayor potencial creativo así que hazle
caso con todo lo que estás escuchando el
día de hoy que te ha jalado y cómo
puedes empezar a explorar un camino por
ahí y el entusiasmo escucharme en acción
es donde te sientes con toda la energía
donde te sientes conectado y donde sabes
que te fascina lo que estás haciendo a
dónde te están llevando tu curiosidad y
tu entusiasmo y el quinto tipo es tu
legado
si pudieras elegir una sola cosa por la
que te gustaría ser recordado por cada
persona que te topes cada día de tu vida
que sería porque eso se va a transformar
en tu legado lleno de tu carisma que es
sonrisa contar chistes tu talento tu
manera de cantar no importa cuál elijas
pero escoge uno que lo puedas hacer
consciente porque tu legado es uno de
tus mayores regalos al mundo así que
date ese lujo de explorar tu carisma
tussam porque cuando tú decides empezar
a buscarlo hay una frase que me encanta
y con esto me voy a despedir de ti el
día de hoy que todo lo que tú buscas ya
está camino a encontrarte muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]